[Musique]
des centaines de réfrigérateurs sur le
bas côté de la
route symbole d'une Amérique
consumériste et triomphante
soudainement balayé par la force d'un
ouragan c'était en septembre
dernier depuis des années les experts
tirent la sonnette d'alarme l'archipel
d'quis est menacé il pourrait un jour
disparaître sous l'effet du changement
climatique
Irma a peut-être été le dernier
avertissement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut Pelusa salut Pandora tout le monde
dit bonjour Voici Pandora dis bonjour
Pandora et là c'est sa sœurousa juste à
côté d'elle c'est une matiné très
spéciale pour Linda la soigneuse en chef
de ce centre de recherche sur les
dauphins je les connais depuis qu'ils
sont tout petits tout bébé comme vos
enfants donc je peux tous les
reconnaître bonjour Comment ça va salut
ê tellement Jol il sont tellement cont
que vous soyez ven manqu de voir du
monde depu
l'ouragan ils vont bien
alors
bien vre FAM est
VI est ok une semaine après le passage
de l'ouragan sur sud de la
Floride les porte de son parc au
visiteur bienvenue merci d'être venu
c'est trop cool
regarde il vient prendre le petit
déjeuner bienvenue à tous bienvenue au
centre de recherche sur les dauphins on
est tellement heureux que vous soyez
tous ici aujourd'hui pour célébrer la
réouverture et le fait que l'ouraganous
pas tué on est là on est pas de
Doutey et notre
famcoup mais en tout cas les dauphins
ont leur maison et c'est ce que l'on
fait aujourd'hui avec vous la tempête
est passée ici comme vous voyez elle a
fait quelques dégâts mais les dauphins
pendant l'ouragan sont restés ensemble
en groupe et se sont réfugés sous l'eau
c'est l'endroit le plus sûr pour
[Applaudissements]
eux dans ces îles les dauphins sont si
nombreux qu'ils sont devenus l'emblème
de la
région ils vont faire la course
[Applaudissements]
regardez venir les admirer après la
tempêteour de sens pour ses premiers
[Rires]
visiteurs c'est dont tout le monde a
besoin des sourires des bons
sentiments n'estce
pasour réchauffer les
cœurs tous sont venus vivre une journée
festive pour oublier ce qu'ils ont
perdu de mois avant l'ouragan voici à
quoi ressemblaent
l'quis des îles paradisiaques relié
entre elles par une route de 200 km de
long mer turquoise sable blanc
végétation
luxuriante une destination très prisée
des
touristes 4 millions sont venus l'an
dernier admirer l'un des plus beaux
écosystèmes au
monde un paradis qui par la main de
l'homme est aujourd'hui menacé condamné
à
disparaître le 10 septembre dernier
l'ouragan sur les
États-Unis catégorie 4 sur une échelle
de 5 il fonce droit sur la Floride
l'état le plus affecté par le
réchauffement climatique et la montée
des
eaux en 15 ans près de 80 tempêtes
tropicales ont ici causé 70 milliards
d'euros de dégâts
Irma menace d'engloutir définitivement
ses 21 millions
d'habitants c'est un ouragon incroyable
il est énorme on attend des vents de 300
kmh donc tout le monde doit écouter les
bulletins officiels d'évacuation soyez
certain d'avoir un plan l'heure est
venue de partir fuyez avant même l'ordre
d'évacuation ceci est un ouragon
nucléaire malgré le plus grand exode de
l'histoire des États-Unis le bilan est
lourd en Floride 30 morts 6 millions de
foyers privés
d'électricité les nombreuses mises en
garde des scientifiques n'auront pas
suffi les vents de 290 km
ont tout balayé sur leur
passage l'eau est monté par endroit
jusqu'à 4 m de
hauteur nous sommes partis à la
rencontre de ceux qui ont survécu à
cetteè tempête certains sont restés
malgré les dangers d'autres s'apprêtent
à partir par choix ou parce qu'ils n'ont
plus rien les premiers réfugiés
climatiques partir ou rester pour
onstruire que faire l'homme peut-il
encore vivre sur ces territoires voué à
disparaître après un exil forcé les
habitants des KIS reviennent pour la
première fois chez
eux pendant la tempête Lisa s'était
réfugié dans sa famille au Mississippi
loin de sa
maison la façade a été complètement
détruite dans les murs et sur le
toit on dirait qu'il y a des affaires
partout des choses de l'intérieur qui
sont à
l'extérieur wou c'est la première fois
que vous revoyez votre maison
oui on vient d'arriver il y a 5 minutes
il y a eu un ordre d'évacuation alors on
a dû partir de la zone et là ils
viennent de nous laisser rentrer pour
faire l'état des lieux vous pouvez voir
la ligne des E
alors on dirait tout lechaussé a été
inondé ici l'eau est monté jusqu'à 1 M50
de hauteur les arbres se sont
littéralement
envolés c'est porte de
frigo c'est qu c'est une partie de mon
frigo les vents de 215 km he ont arraché
la porte de son frigidère qui se
trouvait dans le garage sa maison a subi
la tempête pendant plus de 10
he on peut pas passer par
làau jusqu'au deè étage
regardez ça tout
endommagé la
structure une tempête
destructrice
là je peux mettre mon bras à l'intérieur
de ma maison c'est pas vraiment bon on
doit s'attendre à des dégâts des EAU à
l'intérieur avant de partir Lisa et son
mari avaient pris soin de protéger les
portes avec ses panneaux en
métal mais ils ne savent pas s'ils ont
permis de préserver l'intérieur de leur
maison oh excusez-moi pas de
problème bon c'est le moment de
vérité tout est parfait oui enfin att de
voir les
chambres il y a un trou ici il y a un
trou dans le
mur c'est pas très
grave c'est pas si terrible ça
va
un gros trou dans le mur mais à part
cela peu de dégâts à
l'intérieur un moindre mal pour Lisa
dont la maison a déjà été endommagée par
un ouragan dans le
passé une histoire tristement banal
[Musique]
ici l'archipel subit depuis toujours des
phénomènes météo
violents cette question un homme sur
l'île l'étud depuis plus de 50
ans il travaille à la bibliothèque
municipale de K
West
tomght 75 ans a accumulé ici plus de
60000 documents relatif à l'histoire des
K comme ses premières épreuves d'un
roman Deming
encore toute la presse publié dans la
région voil l'oire
deest pH les docents les plus anciens
datent de 1860 pendant la guerre
civile tout au long de sa carrière il a
constaté que l'histoire DEES est Intim
li à C des
ouragans l'ouragan de 1935 a touché
Islam Morada sur les du
Nord on peut voir des sces de cors qui
flotent
il y en a là are
ici l'ouragan de 1935 est le plus metri
Jama connu lesats-unis
485 de la population de l' de l'époque
les habitantant T de mettre à l'abri
parfois de
manièretonnante oness deenir
nature pouré
proié quand la tempête les a frappé ils
ont été détruits par la violence des
vagues m nature dit non on ne fait pas
ça pourtant l'homme s'est acharné à
vouloir rester défier la nature à coup
de destruction de la mangrove de
réhaussement de
maisons malgré les risques connus la
population a été multipliée par 20 en
moins de 50
ans tout le monde veut vivre dans une
zone côtière où il fait chaud ce n'est
pas que dans les KIS dans toute la
Floride on a le même
problème la population augmente donc on
construit plus de maison et on a plus de
monde dans des zones dangereuses où le
niveau de la mer est vraiment
bas cette situation est aujourd'hui de
plus en plus dénoncée par de nombreux
scientifiques qui ont à de M repris
démontré que Miami est le sud de la
Floride serit sous l'eau dans un futur
pas si lointain que
cela les plus pessimistes parlent de
[Musique]
2040 cela fait longtemps que chrisberg
dénonce cette
situation ce scientifique originaire des
k demande l'arrêt des constructions en
zone
inondable pour nous montrer l'ampleur du
désastre il nous invite à prendre de la
hauteur
partout des constructions anarchiques
parfois en plein milieu de l'océan sans
tenir compte d'une réalité le risque de
tout perdre à chaque ouragan à cause de
la montée des
EAU en moyenne durant les derniers
millénaire on a constaté une toute
petite montée du niveau de la
mer le niveau a augmenté d'environ 22 cm
en 150 ans mais ces 10 dernières années
le phénomène s'est accéléré en 10 ans
l'eau est déjà monté de plus de 20
cm une accélération de la montée des EAU
causée par l'activité humaine qui
réchauffe les océans et fait fondre les
glaces pour le scientifique le
réchauffement climatique joue aussi un
rôle majeur dans la multiplication des
ouragans dans la région et leur
intensité un réel danger pour
l'archipel je peux vous montrer avec
ceéma à quoi ressembla l'quise quand
l'ouragan a frappé l'archipel en
2005 là vous voyez il y a une petite
zone qui n'a pas été
inondée une autre ici auudessus de
l'autoroute une autre aussi près d'une
forêt et une toute petite partie de
cette
île mais tout le reste l'essentiel
desquis de Floride était sous
l'eau les ouragans vont devenir de plus
en plus intenses àuse réchauffement des
océans ces inondations seront de plus en
plus importantes enfin pas seulement les
inondations les vents aussi seront de
plus en plus
forts avec comme conséquence des zones
entières détruites et inhabitables des
milliers de personnes obligé de quitter
leur maison
définitivement si le monde si les
dirigeants ne prennent pas conscience du
problème du changement climatique
sérieusement en réduisant les émissions
de gaz
pass à des énergies
renouvelables dans le futur les endroits
comme les Kiss de Floride seront
submergés et deviendront quasiment
inhabitable dans un futur
procheel je peux déjà voir ces
changements depuis que je suis né et je
pense que d'ici la fin de ma vie je
verrai une montée très significative du
niveau de la mer je verrai des ouragans
très
violents c'est
triste mais c'est la réalité et nous
avons la possibilité de contrôler notre
futur malgré les études et les constats
ces mises en garde de la communauté
scientifique sont trop souvent mis de
côté par l'État de Floride le gouverneur
Rick Scott est l'un des plus fent
climatosceptique du pays l'homme qui
reconnaissait la puissance inédite de
l'ouragan
Irma une tempête meurtrière et l'État
n'a jamais rien connu de tel est aussi
celui qui a supprimé les subventions
pour la protection de l'environnement il
a même interdit de prononcer le terme
réchauffement climatique dans les
réunions officielles gouverneur quel est
votre projet pour lutter contre le
réchauffement
climatique gouverneur quel est votre
projet sur le réchauffement climatique
aucun projet Rick Scott est un proche du
président Donald Trump dont l'absence de
conscience écologique n'est plus à
démontrer Obama n'arrête pas de parler
de ce soi-disant réchauffement
climatique non c'est de l'intox tout ça
de l'intox c'est pour faire de
l'argent je pense que ça change un petit
peu oui un coup il fait froid un coup il
fait un peu plus chaud comme ça l'a
toujours été depuis des millions
d'années ça s'appelle la
météo il faut croire que le message
finit par
passer du moins que nombreux sont ceux
qui minimisent l'impact de ces
variations aujourd'hui 50 000 personnes
vivent dans des zones classées
inondables résultat à chaque ouragan
c'est
lescatombe ce l'autissement de sumerland
Keys a été entièrement construit sur la
mangrve au même niveau que la mer c'est
ici que l'ouragan a été le plus
ravageur cette grande maison turquoise
était le paradis de Rick et Michel
depuis plus de 30 ans c'est là qu'ils
ont élevé leurs trois enfants alors
qu'est-ce qu'on a là des décorations de
Noël
ce foyer le couple ne l'a pas
abandonné ils font partie de ceux qui
n'ont pas voulu croire au danger de
l'ouragan et qui ont bravé l'ordre
d'évacuation avec leur provision leur
kit de survie et leurs baignoir rempl
d'eau potable il se pensaient à l'abri
on est resté dans ces trois pièces là on
avait anticipé on se disait que c'était
les pièces les plus sûres car on venait
de remplacer les portes-fenêtres par des
vitres antiouragan cap de à des vents de
kmh normalement c'est un gros avantage
pour des gens qui sont coincés dans des
ouragan car si vous occultez vos
fenêtres vous ne pouvez rien voir de ce
qui se passe nous on avait cette chance
de voir dehors donc oui on se sentait
bien
ici malheureusement une fois les tr/ de
la tempête passé un morceau du toit nous
est tombé dessus il est alors 4h du
matin ce dimanche 10 septembre
une partie du toit
s'effondre et l'œil de l'ouragan
approche quand l'il est arrivé on se
disait que le pire était passé on s'est
dit c'est bon on va s'en sortir mais
même pas 10 minutes après les pluies
torrenelles sont revenu l'eau est entré
de partout dans 4 ou endroits différents
on devait courir avec des saut et même
pas 10 minutes après le plaf
et c'est là qu'on a réalisé qu'une
énorme masse d'eau était rentré par le
trou causé par la chute d'un arbre
qu'est-ce que vous avez ressenti à ce
momentl on a vraiment eu peur je vous le
dis direct on a vraiment eu
[Musique]
peur ça montait tellement vite que je me
demandais à quel moment ça allait
s'arrêter vent la pluie le souffle ce
son est dur à décrire mais c'était
constant en quelques minutes le canal
devant leur maison déborde et la crue
emporte tout sur son
passage faites attention ça c'était la
tâche pour le bateau et voilà le canal
maintenant il a repris son niveau normal
c'est
redescendu quand mon fils a pris la
vidéo on voit bien les tronses d'eau et
on voit le plot qui
disparaît ce n'était pas simplement des
vagues c'est toute l'eau du canal qui
est
montée là c'est tout abîmé l'eau est
montée jusqu'à 1,50 dans son garage en
quelques secondes avec des maisons
construites sur des terrains exposés au
cru les inondations n'ont laissé aucune
chance à Michel et sa famille
90 % des maisons auquises ont ainsi été
inondé alors pour faire oublier les
conséquences de ce petit problème de
réchauffement climatique le gouvernement
et l'État de Floride préfère payer pour
construire à
l'identique plus de 80 millions d'euros
débloqué à la suite de cet
ouragan à chaque tempête les autorités
ont pris l'habitude de tout mettre en
œuvre pour que la vie continue les
affaires reprennent et que les habitants
restent partout dans l'archipel ils ont
installé des centres de distribution de
vivre gratuit pour prendre soin des
victimes chaque jour des Américains
viennent aussi bénévolement offrir leur
aide dans ce luxueux 44 arrive leur plus
généreuse
donatrice je viens de dépenser 6000
dollars de couche et de lait pour bébé
j'ai besoin d'aide oh c'est incroyable
j'arrive tout de
suite aujourd'hui on apporte des couches
et du lait pour bébé hier on a apporté
des vêtements et des produits de toilett
on vient de for
laudale pourquoi c'est important pour
vous d'être là on doit aider les gens
pourra tre nous on a des dégâs aussi on
a une mais
K et une autre à for on le fait parce
qu'on doit aider les autres c'est
tout les gens don
beaucoup mon dieu c'est bouleversant C
don qui
arrivz les gens pre d'une telle
générositéie de pleer c'est tellement
gques
jours nit ont déjà été
distribué comme à chaque ouragan des
travailleurs de tout le pays ont été
réquisitionné pour établir au plus vite
l'électricité et l'eau
potable CEA viennent du
Texas l'armée aussi met le paquet
elle a recruté un millier d'ouvriers
pour recouvrir les to avec ses BES bleu
capable de protéger les maisons pendant
6 mois là c'est du 4 par
12 du 4 par
12 on essaie de faire le plus vite
possible parce qu'à chaque fois qu'il
pleut tant que le toit n'est pas
recouvert il y a des fes dans la
maison encore plus donc il faut vraiment
faire le plus vite
possible 39000 maisons ont ainsi été
protégé en Floride en seulement 2
semaines toutes les demandes d'urgence
pour l'archipel d'quis sont centralisé
ici au centre opérationnel du comté de
mon médecin Pompi militair ingénieur ce
sont tous des spécialistes de l'urgence
ven là encore de tous les
états-unisok alors là on a plus de
générateur disponible pour l'instant
mais on va recevoir en
principe chaque personne ici a une
mission précise dans notre dispositif
par exemple on les finances
ilontent
en fonction des différentes demandes et
on garde une trace de
tout et ici on a la zone de commandement
les renforts de police il travaille 24
he/
24 madame fait partie de notre équipe
d'urgence elle Mo no troupe depuis de
longues heures
ici voulez-vous expliquer brièvement ce
que vous faites
beaucoup de téléphon et combien
d'app c'est difficile à dire quand c'est
le r ça peut être autour de 100 150 par
he un dispositif de grande ampleur et
des dizaines de million de dollars
d'investissement qui n qu'un seul but
relancer que coûte la première industrie
de
l'archipel
pas du tourisme c'est pourquoi il est
très important pour nous de tout
remettre dans l'ordre le plus vite
possible on travaille très dur pour
aider tous les sinistrés à retrouver une
maison dans l'équise pour qu'ils
retourne au travail s'ils retournent
travailler ils font remarcher l'économie
c'est un cercle vertueux on a besoin de
nos travailleurs mais eux ont besoin
d'un endroit pour
vivre derrière ces maisons de vacances
luxueuses ces hôtels ravagés toute
l'industrie du tourisme so mort 55000
travailleurs au total et eux aussi ont
tout perdu des serveurs animateurs
hôteliers qui vivent principalement dans
des habitations fragiles comme des
mobilhomes des maisons flottantes ou
encore des
bateaux presque toutes ont été détruites
par la violence des vents 7000 personnes
se sont retrouvées sans
domicile des déplacés climatiques au
cœur du pays le plus puissant du monde
mais qui croit encore que la vie est
possible dans cet
archipel BR est l'un
d'entre voil notre
maison que vous voyz là le centre de
pilotage
mangisine les chambr et les ses de
bainé un super endroit un appartement
flottant et c'est complètement détruit
tout ce que nous possédons est quelque
part
là-dessous il vivait ici depuis 1 an
avec sa femme et sa fille de 4
ans ce passionné de la mer avait
entièrement retapé pendant des mois ce
chalutier de 12 m qu'il avait baptisé
Joy la joie qu'est-ce que vous ressentez
quand vous voyez votre bateau comme ça
ça me brise le cœur ça me brise le
[Musique]
cœur je me réconforte en me disant que
ma femme et ma fille sont en
sécurité moi
aussi tout le reste on peut le remplacer
ça va prendre un moment mais on peut
tout
[Musique]
remplacer
depuis 2 semaines Brad et sa famille ont
trouvé refuge dans ce lycée transformé
en abri par la Croix
[Musique]
Rouge il existe une trentaine de refuges
provisoires comme celui-ci mise en place
dans
lesqu comment est votre vie
ici bien c'est mieux que d'être dans la
rue confortable on nous donne à manger
TR fois par jour des affaires pour la
petite des gens
super Laou super travail pour rendre les
choses aussi conforbl que possible V les
circstan estce que votre fille comprend
ce qui se passe elle est un peu jeune
pour comprendre que les choses ont
vraiment
changé
elle vit au jour le jour et nous on
essaie de faire en sorte que ces
journées se passent le mieux
possible voilà ce qu'on a avec nous tout
ce qui le reste ti dans cette peti
valise emport précipitamment juste avant
la
tempête on a des vêts pour se changer
pour nous et pour le
bébé BR à cheveux
des produits de toilettes la plupart de
ces choses nous ont été donné ici par
exemple je nétais parti qu'ave des
shorts et j'espère que je pourrai
retourner au travail la semaine
prochaine d'prs et j'ai besoin de
pantalon tout ça c'est des
dons malgré la difficulté BR n' aucun
doute il vaevivre dans son
bateaue les
habits habitué à croire en
l'avenir un optimisme que l'État de
Floride cultive à coup de millions il a
embauché l'élite des ingénieurs pour
aider les habitants des KIS à continuer
à vivre ici malgré les
risquesonazis travaille à l'Université
de Floride il est à la tête d'un
programme de plus de 2 millions de
dollars qui étudie l'impact des ouragans
sur les habitations lui ne cherche pas à
comprendre la cause de leur
multiplication sa mission est de trouver
un nouveau type de construction de le
résister parti de Miami il lui faut
d'abord passer les contrôles de police
avant d'arriver dans l'quise al bonjour
Comment ça va on était là hier merci
seul les résidents et les travailleurs
sont autorisés à passer pour éviter les
pillages son terrain de recherche se
trouve à Big Pinky la ville la plus
touchée desquis 530 maisons ont été
totalement
détruite c'est un quartier résidentiel
typique de cette région là vous voyez
les maisons sont tout plus ou moins
toutes construit de la même
manière les gens connaissent bien la
violence des ouragans
ici alors il constru des maisons
suré lecha n pas occupé c'est souvent un
garageage les maisons surélevé ont
permis d'éviter les inondations mais les
vents ont tout
ravagé c'est un cas très
intéressant exactement ce qu'on
recherche on a une première maison
complètement détruite la deè
complètement détruite la trè
complètement détruite et ensuite on a
des maisons à côté plus ou moins en bon
état donc ma première impression c'est
qu'il y a dû avoir une tornade à
l'intérieur de
l'ouragan c'est très intéressant pour
nous car on a plusieurs
messages bonjour on est de l'université
on fait des recherches sur les dommages
on prend des photos on cherche à savoir
ce qui s passé vous AZ des dégâts sur to
les non ça l'air
d'aller
OK pas de dégât majeurs chez cet homme
dont la maison a été construite
[Musique]
récemmentisance de son
[Applaudissements]
garage son
les
que est le problème ce sont les
inondations
qu'est-ce que ça représente pour vous ce
sont des semaines des mois pour
reconstruire une maison comme
ça je n'en ai aucune
idée si un jour je peux revenir cela va
être long avant que ça ne redevienne
comme avant j'ai perdu ma voix j'ai du
mal à parler à force d'avoir crier et
pleurer vous avez traversé beaucoup de
choses ces rencontres sur le terrain
sont capital pour le chercheur elles
vont lui permettre d'évaluer la
résistance des maisons dans les
il y a différents types d'habitation ici
différents types de construction de toit
de
technique donc on veut comprendre
comment chaque maison a
résisté en comparant les données de
l'observation que l'on fait avec les
données sur le vent que l'on a on pourra
avoir une très bonne idée de comment ce
système a fonctionné pourquoi les dégâts
surviennent est-ce un problème de
maintenance une maison nouvelle ou une
viille maison le type de construction
tout ceci est très utile pour
nous grâce à ses études de terrain
yonasis va pouvoir tester les différents
types d'habitation qu'il a croisé ici
celles qui ont tenu et celles qui sont
détruites et pour ces test là encore les
États-Unis n'ont pas laésiner sur les
moyens le wall of wind en français le
mur du vent est une
avec ses 12 ventilateurs la machine est
capable de simuler des vents égaux à 240
km he comparable à ce d'un ouragan
commema nous y retrouvonsonasis et un de
ses
collègues c'est un test d'intrusion
d'eau pendant une
tempête l'idée est de simuler l'eau qui
rentre par une fenêtre cassée en
mesurant la qué qui rent dans la maison
li au taux d'humidité dans les murs on
va pouvoir estimer l'ampleur des
[Musique]
dégâts une fois les ventilateurs géant
enclenchés et les l d'eau dispersé on a
l'impression qu'une tempête tropicale s
de plus en plus
forte on commence ce test en exposant le
côté de la maison constru pour résister
à la pluie
en l'exposant à des vents forts auun
problème mais quand on tour la maison
de0° que le côté construit avec des
matériaux classiques et percutés par des
vents de 290 kmh on voit bien c'est un
désastre un vrai
d c'est une bonne démonstration pour
montrer les différences entre les
maisons nor de construction très élevé
et des maisons plus vieilles comme cell
queon Aser dans les
aprs on déjà prouvé par exemple que les
toits métalliques sont les plus
résistants mais les constructions même
les plus solides pourront-elles tenir le
choc face à des phénomènes climatiques
extrêmes aujourd'hui on sait exactement
ce qui se passe jusqu'à une certaine
puissance de vent mais audelà de 240 kmh
c'est une force tellement importante qui
s'abat sur le toit et sur toute
l'infrastructure des
habitations que même si le bâtiment est
construit avec des normes
élevé doend de gros dégâts donc on est
forcément inquiet pour le
futur cette fois-ci la science et les
technologies n'ont rien pu faire Irma a
été la plus
forte ceux d'hier qui ont bravé
l'ouragan sont ceux qui aujourd'hui
doivent partir et tout
abandonner ça ça reste ça ne vient pas
avec moi à Summerland Kys Rick et Michel
se préparent à quitter leur maison
ils rejoignent les rang des déplacés
climatiques la chute d'une partie de
leur toit et l'inondation de leur garage
ont provoqué des dégâts qui empirent de
jour en
jour pourquoi vous partez et bien parce
que ce n'est plus vivable la chaleur
c'est quelque chose mon mari en souffre
terriblement moi ça ne me dérange pas
mais la chaleur sans climatisation c'est
terrible mais le plus gros problème
c'est l'humidité la moisissure Mons n'a
jamais eu d'asthme il respire très mal
maintenant à cause de la moisessure sur
les
murs pourtant le couple est assuré il
paye même 850 € par mois pour se
protéger contre le vent la pluie et les
inondations dans une région aussi
habituée aux ouragans il pensaient que
les 170000 € de travaux nécessaires aux
réparation allaient être pris en charge
par leurs courtiers mais la visite va
vite les démoraliser elle n'a pas
souhaité être filmée nous l'enregistrons
en camé
discrète vous allez payer pour la
Mure juste le nettoyage on p le
nettoyage mais c'est tout on peut vous
installer des ventilateurs c'est ce que
tout le monde fait pour faire sécher les
murs au final l'assurance annonce
qu'elle Pera au mieux 15 % des travaux
26000 € sur les 170000
nécessaires un coup dur pour le
couple donc les murs de l'Intérieur ne
sont pas couverts
ok j'espère que les dégâts du
rez-dechaussée causés par l'au qui est
entré par le toit seront pris en charge
par la
sence en Floride il y a trois types de
couverture une pour le vent une pour les
inondations et une autre pour le feu et
la responsabilité
civile on app la dernière mais pour un
ouragan ils ne sont responsabl de
rien payz une assurance pour rien à peu
près oui mais en même temps si vous
voulez un prê la banque vous demande une
assurance sans aide ni solution ils ne
savent pas quand ils pourront commencer
leurs travaux ni même s'ils arriveront à
sauver leur
maison le lendemain c'est l'heure du
départ celui-là reste et celui-là
part ils vont prendre la route vers le
connecticket à 2500 km de chez eux où
une partie de leur famille va les
héberger bon je crois que c'est tout
pour
l'instant leur fils est chargé de vider
la maison pendant leur absence pour
préserver leurs affaires de
l'humidité ok mon
fils c'est bientôt
fini
c'est un moment difficile dans votre vie
ça oui je ne vais pas le voir pendant un
moment parce qu'il va travailler sur le
projet de reconstruction ici donc tu
viendras à oui pour Noël ok je suis le
chef de chantier je pars quand je veux
c'est
bien rappelle-toi n'oublie pas le masque
le masque surtout pour le
à cause de ce genre de
truc quand on va travailler on va devoir
porter
ça il faut juste
s'habituer bien maintenant tu es prêt à
travailler tu as plus de raison de
t'quéter maintenant aucun
souci dans la connu sans savoir s'il
reverront un jour leur petit paradis
Brad l'amoureux de la mer quant à lui a
perdu tout espoir il ne revivra plus
jamais dans cette
marina cétaun de nos endroits préférés
pour manger on venait prendre le petit-
dééjeuner et le déjeuner tout le temps
c'est une sorte de souvenir de la vie
que l'on avait
avant un mois après l'ouragan les
nouvelles ne sont pas
bonnes le refuge de la Croix Rouge a
fermé ses portes depuis il occupe une
chambre dans un motel de bord de
route sa femme a préféré partir avec
leur fille à charlestone à plus de 1000
km de là chez des
amis on affronte plusieurs gros
problèmes financiers on va devoir
déménager on ne peut plus vivre ici
il n'y a plus de maison abordable pour
nous notre bateau est cassé et on ne va
pas pouir le réparer pour en refaire une
maison la loi oblige BR à sortir son
épave de l'eau coup de l'opération 3500
€ pour s'en débarrasser il a dû mettre
en vente son bateau à un prix
dérisoire ilques
jours
touris une autre mauaise
nouvelle le département pour lequel je
travaillais a décidé de fermer donc on
est s
domicile
ch je pas dire ça mais la
réalité
chage
caused chômage à
cause
en tout il serait 10000 personnes à
avoir quitté l'archipel depuis
l'ouragan les autres la grande majorité
ont décidé de rester malgré les
destructions et les prédictions
alarmistes des
scientifiques un Paris sur
l'avenir si la prochaine tempête
pourrait bien leur être fatale leur vie
est
ici pour la plupart ils n' connu que ce
bout de terre depuis leur naissance
parti manuel cartel ne s'est même pas
poser la question il est pêcheur de
l'angous de père en fils depuis 43
ans regardez
[Applaudissements]
devant personne n'est encore sorti avec
le bateau on est les premiers beaucoup
de dégâts dans l'eau on sait pas ce
qu'il y a dans l'eau après la
tempête pourquoi vous sortez aujourd'hui
B pour voir quels sont les dégâts dans
nos casiier les dégâts qu'on a au
large c'est important pour vous ouais
bien sûr
pourquoi parce que tout notre argent est
là-bas la pêche c'est la deuxè ressource
économique des KIS 4500 personnes en
vivent manuel ne connaît que ça
impossible pour lui de renoncer à cette
affaire familiale aujourd'hui il espère
trouver quelques langoues de quoi
relancer son business José on peut aller
vérifier cette bouée on va voir par
là-bas problème les casiers ont été
éparpillés par la force de
l'ouragan après une demi-heure de
recherche il arrive à trouver une de ces
lignes tout est emêlé les lignes en
dessous de l'eau sont tout
emmêlé d'ordinaire manuel remonte au
moins 50 langostes par
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
casier mais dans
celui-ci de langou seulement et beaucoup
de
sable ça devrait pas être plein de sable
comme ça t les débris et le sable que
l'ouragon a poussé dedans ça devrait
être très propre sans rien d'autre que
les
langoues
combien de langou vous avez attrapé
aujourd'hui là il y a pratiquement rien
rien combien d'argent vous avez perdu
alors
beaucoup comment vous dire au moins 3
4000 dollarsou 4000 par jour
par jour
ou soit plus de 100000 € de perte depuis
le passage
d'Irma
pour manuel et tous les pêcheurs de
l'angouste les de mois les plus
importants de la saison sont perdus en
tout 100000 casier ont disparu 80% de la
production desqu est parti à
l'eau ça va prendre du temps pour que
tout devienne normal au moin plusieurs
mois pour l'instant plus personne ne
vient
ici nous on vit grâce au touristes les
c'est que du tourisme mais ne va vouloir
venir maintenant que tout est
dévasté sans le retour des touristes
manuel et tous les pêcheur de l'île
risqu de rester à quai faute de
travail pour l'instant tout est fermé
les restaurants les hôtels faute de
touristes sans eux pas de business et
surtout pas
d'argent alors pour les faire revenir le
plus vite possible le maire a organisé
un gros coup de
[Musique]
com c'était de semaines seulement après
la tempête alors que les maisons sont
encore à terre il a fait revenir un
premier bateau de croisière sous l'œil
des caméras et c'est lui-même chemise à
fleur et grand sourire qui a accueilli
les premiers touristes merci d'être venu
quel plaisir de vous voir passer une
bonne journée je suis super contente
d'être
ici on est une économie basée sur le
tourisme donc on a besoin que nos
visiteurs reviennent c'est notre
première économie il faut qu'il vienent
voir nos merveilleux paysages nos villes
notre
architecture les serves les barm les
hôtels dépendent tous de ces touristes
les gens ont besoin de retourner au
travail et c'est la plus grosse partie
de notre
reconstruction depuis toujours malgré la
menace constante des ouragans les
habitants s'accroch à ces paysages de
carte postal et croise les doigts pour
ne jamais devoir les quitter
la vie reprend aujourd'hui timidement
ses
droits k West la dernière île de
l'archipel le point le plus au sud
destats-unis une
rendue célèbre par ernesting ou encore
ten Williams qui ont vécu
ici tu
as est insté il y a 30 ans il tient la
première distillerie de Rome de la ville
so
asulire la première fteuis
l'ouragan on va faire un coil qui
s'appelle diableouragan avec limonade au
gingembre pour que les G oubl pe la
tempte que re bon pour tout le monde de
reler ESTs ce
momentpe mais je pon ça ce soir de
nouveau
direction Malori square la place
emblématique de Ky
[Musique]
West inhabituellement déserté depuis
l'ouragan elle retrouve ce soir son
esprit libre et
festif on veut être tous ensemble ce
soir pour dire qu'on a survécu à la
tempête on est là la vie est belle
il faut la vivre comme si c'était le
dernier jour on ne sait jamais ce qui va
se
passer j'espère qu'on fera ça tous les
ans pour l'anniversaire du passage de
l'ouragan sur les KIS que tous les
locaux se rassemblent et célèbr le fait
qu'on a tous
[Musique]
survécu ça va les gars après la
tempettete oh ouais moi ouais ça va mais
lui il a perdu deux
maisons
de il en a perdu une et il était en
train d'en rénover une autre donc il en
a perdu deux en tout
tu sais ce qui est bien c'est que tu
gardes le sourire et ça
j'adore demain les écoles les banques et
les administrations ouvriront de
nouveau mais pour
l'heure poussez-moi si je vous bloque la
[Musique]
vue Paul et ses voisins veulent prendre
le temps d'admirer le coucher de soleil
ce qui est cool c'est que d'habitude il
n'y a que des touristes qui viennent
s'asseoir ici avec leur appareil photo
c'est la première fois que je ne vois
que des locaux prendre des photos du
coucher de soleil la sont jamais ven
parce qu'il travaill à C donc ça CR
quelque chose de vraiment
spécial comme pour conj
leort c'est
[Applaudissements]
partti le drapeau des gardô qui ind la
tempête est
brlé
[Applaudissements]
cette île est une survivante depuis 185
ans on est des survivants
ici peu importe ce qui arrive on
reconstruit d'une manière ou d'une
autre mais la façon dont on survie c'est
avec les autres les gens cdent si j'ai
quelque chose aujourd'hui je vais le
donner à quelqu'un d'autre quand j'ai
besoin de quelque chose l'autre jour un
mec s'est arrêté il m'a dit vous essayez
de couper l'arbre vous êtes tout seul il
s'est arrêté il m'a aidé je ne le
connaissais même pas
ce soir les habitants d'quis assisteront
unis à ce coucher de soleil qui fait la
réputation de
l'archipel un archipel qu'ils ont décidé
de ne pas quitter ils resteront malgré
les
avertissements combien de temps
pourront-ils encore
[Musique]
tenir